the corona virus outbreak it is taking a
serious turn in California where a
cruise ship is being held off the coast
right now California's governor declared
a state of emergency after its first
death from coronavirus illness the
victim was a passenger on that ship this
is the first known death in the u.s.
outside Washington State where at least
ten people have died 160 other people
are infected in 17 states including at
least 54 in California Jamie yuccas is
in San Francisco where the cruise ship
was supposed to arrive last night Jamie
what's happening now well Anthony the
ship off the coast here is not expected
to dock until passengers on board can be
tested for the virus a 71 year old man
on the same ship last month died
yesterday several passengers on board
now might have the virus as well this is
where the princess cruise ship was
expected to dock last night in San
Francisco it sets sail last month and
now the Grand Princess is ordered to
remain offshore over coronavirus fears
we are going to be flying testing kits
to the cruise ship and we are going to
be sending those quickly back to the
state and primarily to Richmond lab
where we'll be able to test very quickly
Lee Carlson and her sister Laura are now
on board the ship they say they couldn't
sleep after hearing what happened
[Music]
take it to my city if I have no further
south in Los Angeles County there are
now six confirmed cases including a
medical screener at Los Angeles
International Airport the potential
public health risk is elevated and
significant we expect to see more cases
as we announced here today
health officials from coast to coast
continue to try to stop the virus from
spreading in Washington state where a
tenth person died yesterday at this
nursing home an old Econolodge motel
will be turned into a quarantine
facility and in New York several schools
have closed after an outbreak in
Westchester County coronavirus patient
lawrence Garr booze is recovering
medical authorities say the infection of
the 50 year old has spread to nine other
people including three members of his
own family his neighbor and another
family we're now playing this game
oh one here one here one here whack
Amole it is going to be dozens and
dozens and dozens now Amazon is asking
its employees in Seattle to work from
home for the rest of the month after a
worker tested positive for the virus
back here in California the governor
said the state would reach out to every
county with passengers on that cruise
ship to keep local officials updated
Tony Jamie thank you very much
you